[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
fortnite is packed with so many skins
these days so many that you'd need to
spend thousands of dollars pounds
euros and rupees to own them all some
skins though
aren't just here to make us feel happy
regardless of the thickness
some skins are legitimate characters in
the fortnite story
and today we are celebrating fortnite
characters linked to the story
that don't get enough attention from
epic games
be sure to use the comments below to
tell me which skins should be in this
list
and if you'd be so kind to slap code
adamaru in the store to support videos
like this
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes and
let's do this
begin with the enforcers do you remember
these guys
this is a strange story which like many
others in this list
ends before it even starts but this
season
has opened up a million possibilities
back in season 5 of chapter 1 the same
season drift arrived
another unlockable skin appeared they
arrived in the same way as drift
rifting here but unlike drift their
appearance was not a random event
they came here to investigate the
anomalies of worlds colliding
sounds just like the season we're in
right back then their riot shields
indicated they were like an
intergalactic police force
and their description confirmed it
balance and order
must be restored these guys were here to
put right the illegal use of reality
convergence
i kind of see him like the vegan police
in scott pilgrim
free speaking police if you have any
idea what i mean there you have my
respect
for weeks we waited for more information
for something to happen
why were the police here what dimensions
had opened up
and will they catch drift nothing at all
happened
for years no answers no development
nothing at all now in chapter two season
five
we saw inside the imagined order whilst
johnsy was being briefed the troops
running around looked very similar to
the enforcers
almost like the io troops are the elite
versions
of the enforcers side by side it's easy
to see they could be related in some way
and there's even symmetry here too
chapter 1 season 5
saw the enforcers chapter 2 season 5
sees the io commandos the enforcers in
chapter 1 known as worlds collide
and the io commandos in chapter 2 where
the worlds are
literally colliding this is very
deliberate
the io troops are attempting to help jon
jones in his mission to stop all
escapees and restore balance and order
to the island
wait a sec what was the enforcer's
description again
oh balance and order must be restored
could they be the same troops but loops
apart
what do you reckon i spoke to a few
people about this on my discord
and they also suggested that fusion from
chapter 2 could be another form of
enforcer
and io guard from a futuristic loop they
do share similarities i guess
and that would also explain the back
blink there
have we found the real reason the
enforcers didn't capture drift in
chapter one they were sent to watch
and record the anomaly and now the i o
troops are popping up all over the
island
answers will be coming very soon
the next character who needs more
respect than they get is the chaos agent
the slender man looking dude with an
iconic mask
do you remember the first time we saw
him though it was all the way back
in chapter one when gotham city replaced
tilted towers
those were some crazy times he was there
hiding in a poster
fast forward to chapter two and chaos
agents became pivotal to the story
but only the dedicated law followers
knew about him
using all the evidence presented we can
surmise he was a leader of sorts in the
shadow ranks
so much so that his mask was their
emblem chaos agent may look human from a
distance but his appearance is
completely alien
behind the mask his real features are
well
this and his hands do not look of this
world
suddenly a loading screen made things
clearer but also opened up
way more questions chaos agent watching
over numerous screams
we see a sludge army being assembled in
secret we've all come to believe that
chaos agent is experimenting with the
slurpy swamps
and the mythical power of kevolution i
feel the kevolution part is important
as similar symbols on the cube can be
found on the back of the agent's head
and once again the story of chapter 1 is
repeating in chapter 2.
season 4 of both chapters were about
superheroes and season 5 was when kevin
first appeared
so it makes sense that we'll see him
again this season i'm keeping an eye on
steamy stacks in anticipation
anyways back to the image on another
screen we see that the chaos agent has
connections to big chungus
again suggesting his experimentations
are progressing
and he seems to be making a super
soldier program
but all the while a key question
remained about chaos agent was he
working for midas
maybe alongside midas or maybe
controlling him
from behind the scenes in one of the
chaos agents final acts he created the
slurp soldiers
a mess of human beings and blue slurpee
goodness
but before we could take this any
further chaos agent vanished
gone without a trace the cut scene which
depicts midas turning masks into
trophies
shows us chaos agent's mask hinting that
midas had either converted chaos agent
to his beliefs
or taken him out to protect his work on
the device
and the zero point and get this that
theory is actually backed up by the
chaos double agent skin
midas his golden hands changing chaos
agent forever
linking back once again to the fable of
king midas
right now midas isn't here anymore will
we ever see the chaos agent again i hope
so
his experimentation has left a constant
reminder on the island of his legacy
now let's end this with a massive
bombshell the description for chaos
agent reads
undermined the order from the shadows
the order this meant little in previous
seasons but now we know of the imagined
order
this statement means so much more
undermine the order from the shadows
does this mean chaos agent is still
around and doing what he promised to
undermine the imagined order from the
shadows ready to unleash his sludge
troops
we don't know right now but i'll bet the
chaos agent will return to continue his
experimentation at the swamp and steamy
stacks
and i really think it's time for kevin
to make a big impact
on the story
[Music]
let's move on to another character we
all love that of midas
and a solid story theory we've had for a
while now but i'm gonna throw
a different light on this let's set the
scene the person solely responsible for
revealing the isle headquarters to us
is midas when the man with the golden
touch arrived in chapter two season two
many of us immediately drew parallels
with his namesake king midas from the
fable
told about his desire for wealth which
almost cost him
everything when the oro skin arrived we
all expected a story centered around the
pair
their matching scars their golden
abilities their blind desire for
power were these the same person but
nothing happened at all their
similarities were never spoken of again
then things took a different direction
the end of the season revealed midas
true intentions to push back the storm
and escape the loop
utilizing the zero point and this is
when we saw the most
important skin arrive cyclo we first saw
this in madison's room at the rig
the rig then blew up and finally
completely decayed and fell apart
at the end of the season but not before
we saw the suit
of unknown power we also 100
know this belonged to midas thanks to
the loading screen depicting his
reflection in the glass
he made this suit or at least had it
made shortly after this
cyclo appeared in the store for us to
purchase a completely unique skin with
designs unseen before
and once again the description gives us
more information it told us his plan
defy the storm on the final day of the
season midas completed his device and
harnessed the zero point to repel the
storm
long enough to allow us to leave the
loop for a few moments
thus fleeting iconic seconds in agent
jones's office
we quickly believed midas failed in his
attempt to leave the loop
as days later he finally met his
comeuppance thanks to a chance encounter
with a shark
he then returned in undead form as a
halloween menace
and he was a fish too right weird it was
around this point
we learned about snapshots a clone of
any character
who enters the loop it wasn't until
season five that we were given more
information about midas
and look who gives us it it's jon jones
the version from season nine
of chapter 1. he was the chap with
foresight he could see the future before
it happened
and in game right now he tells us to
keep it quiet i don't think the midas
that returned
is the same midas so i started thinking
about this
this could simply be a throwaway line to
make us all understand snapshots in
fortnite
but what if the midas who returned
wasn't the same midas
as that one in season three because i
think
he escaped the loop lining everything up
we see the cyclo skin was
teased added and removed from the store
quicker than any other skin there has
been before
it's highly likely midas device did in
fact work
and thanks to wearing that cyclo armor
he made it
out of the loop leaving behind this poor
snapshot
to take the ball midas put everything in
motion
showing us all the zero point where it
was hidden under the island
and accidentally showing galactus
exactly where it was
too he caused the zero point to begin
breaking realities
and combining worlds together and most
importantly
bringing agent johnsy onto the fortnite
island again with the one item
that can change reality heck even the
mustard we call donald told us to keep
an eye on jones's tool
this season so it isn't too far-fetched
to think that one version of midas
actually got out of the loop
and the one who was eaten and the dark
variant and the fish
were all previous snapshots could cyclo
be one of the seven
or is midas acting alone and if he did
get out
what would be his next plan like usual i
hand this over to you
what do you think of those three
characters and their importance on the
story
are any of these theories true and which
of the characters should we be keeping
an eye on
i'll be looking in the comments to see
what you guys think please upvote your
favorites so i can find them easier next
time and let's break this code and
figure out the story of chapter two
thanks to everyone who supported me by
using code adamaru here's a bunch of
more legends on the screen now
i really appreciate it thank you very
much i'm adam from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you